investigators say the crash off a
California cliff that killed a
Washington State family may have been
intentional the California Highway
Patrol says the SUV carrying Jennifer
and Sarah Hart and at least three of
their adopted children drove straight
off the cliff without stopping there are
three other children are missing but are
presumed dead
vladimir duthiers of our extremly
network cbsn is here now with new
details but this was a heartbreaking
story last week to hear it might have
been done on purpose takes it to a whole
home yeah the whole country feels for
this family because of little Devante
heart we saw that photo of him
the Sheriff's Office says it believes at
least one felony was committed in this
case it won't say what that felony is or
why it believes that but new details are
starting to help us understand what may
have happened on that Northern
California clip the California Highway
Patrol says electronic data pulled from
the Hart SUV is helping piece together
the family's final tragic moments
preliminary information shows the SUV
pulled off highway 1 stopping on a dirt
turn around about 70 feet from the
cliff's edge police say the vehicle then
accelerated plunging straight into the
Pacific Ocean there were no skid marks
found on the scene or signs the driver
tried to brake authorities described the
SUV speedometer as pinned at 90 miles
per hour
but investigators say that number could
have been caused by the impact of the
crash late last week investigators
searched Sarah and Jennifer Hart's home
in Woodland Washington where they had
recently moved with their six adopted
children
authorities say no suicide note was
found they portray this happy little
family but neighbors like Dana DeKalb
say there were signs of trouble
prompting her to call Child Protective
Services their daughters telling us
please please please begging is not to
make her go back and that they were
abusing her in 2011 when the family
lived in Minnesota Sarah Hart pleaded
guilty to domestic assault according to
court documents she admitted she bent
her six year old daughter over a bathtub
and hit her on the back side there was
no question as to how
completely loved and adored those
children were zippy Lomax met the family
in 2012 and said she is shocked by
allegations of abuse
none of that lines up with the people
that we all knew it's really hard to
imagine Child Protective Services
visited the family home at least three
times in days before the crash but never
saw the Hart's investigators say they
have written search warrants for the
couple's cellphone and bank records as
of now they do not know why the family
was in California you're sorry about
those kids in that car probably had no
idea this was coming yeah very sad story